hey i look at myself
and i'm like
wow i i i'm in shock about my own
actions you know i wish i could take the
the time back to the past and act in a
better way but it's kind of late start
with the saying it's always the same you
always made me look crazy i never said
yes you do you're always defending that
you got temptation and you're comparing
me to herod
jasmine we have so much to talk about
first of all are you watching the show
back every week uh yes uh i'm watching
the show as of your i can
i can tell you that i'm enjoying a lot
watching the other couples you know i'm
so into what's going to happen next it's
so interesting
but then when it comes to my story it
hit me differently you know it's always
um
kind of hard i judge myself a lot on my
actions you know
because sometimes i was like
uh out of control you know
for some of the things that i did on the
show and um it helped me just to have
like a self-reflection
on myself
you have something with a waitress
it has nothing to do you have something
with a waitress do you have any regrets
about your behavior toward geno
specifically your jealous behavior
absolutely i regret i believe it was
like way too much maybe
it's
i believe that it is okay expressing how
you feel what would be dangerous is not
letting the person know how you feel you
know but maybe my approach the way i
express those feelings was definitely
not the best because i was being way too
emotional
and you have to understand that i was
and it has nothing to do with gino it
has everything to do with me okay it
could have been gino or any other guy i
was dating my reaction will still be the
same because i was the problem you know
i was coming from a very
difficult relationship in which i was
getting divorced there were my two kids
involved you know i was very vulnerable
and
i was being very emotional and i didn't
i then i was so
so like so many years
without being in a romantic relationship
with a man you know and it was difficult
for me to
get used to you know having someone and
expressing my feelings the best way but
if i regret absolutely uh it was way way
too much do you ever see yourself easing
up on your jealousy for instance not
getting mad if he wants to tip a
waitress or if he's talking to another
woman
yes uh i believe that um
i can get to that point because
as i said the problem is
the problem was not that i didn't trust
you know okay it's not like it's like
me the way i i look at myself you know
like i look at myself uh at that moment
in my life like oh i'm not enough you
know i i was feeling like um
i was not worthy you know and i i saw
like every woman like you know like a
treat to my relationships threat yeah
it's coming from trauma trauma in the
past
trauma from my childhood
trauma from my broken marriage i can see
that watching myself
in the show and i get mad because i'm
the biggest judge on myself like what
were you thinking that thing with the
white dress was way too much
and in real life i'm a super sweet kind
person i couldn't believe i said that i
couldn't believe i refused to
let gino give a tip um
it's like i'm watching this girl and i
can't believe that's myself you
understand what i mean
i think what you're saying is really
relatable you know some some of us might
not have gone to the extreme levels that
you have but
trauma will cause you to see things that
aren't even happening
a woman is looking at your man and you
think she wants your man and she really
doesn't trauma will do that so what are
some of the things you're doing to heal
that trauma and work on yourself i'm
doing a lot of meditation you know a lot
of reflection
as a literature teacher i love writing i
put my emotions into words and paper
and i'm trying to not to judge myself as
hard as i used to do in the past because
then i feel even worse and more guilty
and and that's not you know that's
that's negative as well
every day i've been with you where i
feel like our bonds we haven't grown
we're growing like a closer
bond and a
we're having a better connection you
know
let's talk gino because he loves you
he has stood by your side through it all
what is it about geno that attracts you
to him that has you wanting to marry
this man i like him physically first of
all i believe like he's a very
attractive man he is like very calm
person
he likes process
he doesn't
let himself get too emotional by the
heat of the situations you know and he's
extremely sweet very sweet guy you know
and that's a gentleman and that's though
to me those were qualities very hard to
find in a man nowadays is gino's head
that bad
do you ever think he'll get comfortable
enough to show it i mean that is
something that only gino can answer i
believe you know but from my perspective
uh there is nothing wrong with his head
i truly believe that he looks even
better
without the hat you know he looks very
attractive
uh i think that this actor bruce willis
i believe destiny you know he's kind of
you know the same shape and everything
and we're talking about hollywood actor
and he looks very similar uh to to this
person without the hat so it has nothing
to do with the way he looks because he's
still attracted with without the head
he's not comfortable with this new
version of himself that is without the
hair
and only time will tell if he will
eventually be comfortable you know being
outside without wearing a hat to be
honest well coming up it seems as if
we're going to learn that gino isn't as
innocent as we probably thought
apparently
his ex tells you that he sent her naked
pictures of you
did you send her naked pictures of me
i know you can't tell us much but what
can you tease
uh i can just tell you that
[Music]
it was
it was super sad for me
the way you know i i i was given this
information it was very shocking
i was not expecting it
uh especially because all the time i was
telling myself that this topic with the
excess was all in my mind it was all in
my head
and you know uh
i was not that wrong my intuition was
kind of right because he was still
communicating uh with uh his ex more
than being mad
uh
it's something
disappointing for me
you know is it it's like a violation to
to your privacy and especially coming
from someone you you you love yeah okay
well speaking of that there are some
rumors circulating that geno has been in
a sugar daddy sugar sugar baby
situation in his previous relationship
what do you have to say about that you
know what even if it is true or not i
believe we all have a past you know
we'll have a past and i i cannot judge
from what he did in his past
relationships
i
i do believe that he so far as you can
see in the show he has
shown me that he's a good person that
he's so into me
i mean this man
has not run away from me after showing
my my super
crazy and wild side if he did it it's
just out of
loneliness and wanting
money company and i know that back in
the united states you know before he
lost his job he was a very busy man
was working all the time and maybe i
don't know he didn't have the time to go
and take girls and he rely on this
website
i don't really know you know
but uh i i believe that you know overall
he he's a good man and he will never
disrespect a woman for sure well are
there any misconceptions
that 90 day fans might have about you
that you want to set straight being a
gold digger you're like
you know i'm constantly calling these
names like hey you're a gold digger but
let me tell you something girl if i'm
gonna date someone for his money it's
gonna be like
filthy bridge you know like millionaire
like tons of money if there is no love
involved i'm gonna find a man like he's
like super super super rich uh
not you know that is more like average
you know so people those are
misconceptions and i always laugh about
it like give me break come on
you